hi I'm Stacey Greenbaum I'm the costume
designer for broad city
I have a couple of favorite moments one
really really amazing moment this season
so far is Alana in the matrix I'm going
to look that's his I am the Internet I
am the matrix I am the future and the
future is female as well as paperless
I've been waiting for this since 1999
rather than covering a lot of up we
created this really hilarious trench
back Kate so that it gave her a lot of
movement we made her this really
fantastic choker that is a myriad of
different computer cords which was just
a riot along with her really micro
glasses okay this is my favorite
sweatshirt it's this sweatshirt this is
Abby's real original sweatshirt from
mica it's been washed a hundred thousand
times it's actually a vintage sweatshirt
with like the perfect amount of where'sa
like oh I don't want this I went to
RISD this actually is my assistant
designer Val's moms dress from the 80s
which looked unbelievable on Ilana I
farted and it went I got my dress not my
nose and then it dissipated Harrod
beautifully like these earrings that we
made so that she could just be more of
who she is Tom and I thought of you
why just kidding these costumes are best
shown together for a B we have this
really colorful playful shirt and jeans
if you recall back to the pilot a lot of
ends that episode wearing a shirt that
says I love you easy or not exactly
those words but pretty close so we
decided we would bring it back with some
electrical tape on this costume it's
just a really fun moment I love how
colorful and playful they are how old
are y'all anyway I can't tell because
the outfits aren't matching the faces
next
[Music]